the validity of special relativity
is a consequence of the fact that in
some sense it doesn't matter
in what order you do these underlying
things so long as they respect
this kind of set of causal relationships
so that's that's uh you know
the the part that's in a certain sense
is a really important one but the fact
that
it it sometimes doesn't matter that's a
i don't know that's another like
beautiful okay so so that there's this
idea of
what i call causal invariance causal and
variance exactly
so that's really really powerful right
powerful idea which has actually
arisen in different forms many times in
the history of mathematics mathematical
logic
even computer science has many different
names um
i mean our particular version of it is a
little bit tighter than other versions
but it's basically the same idea here's
here's how to think about that idea so
imagine that
well let's talk about it in terms of
math for a second let's say you're doing
algebra
and you're told you know multiply out
this
series of polynomials that are that are
multiplied together okay
you say well which order should i do
that in say well do i multiply the third
one by the fourth one and then do it by
the first one or do i do the fifth one
by the sixth one and then do that
well it turns out it doesn't matter you
can you can multiply them out in any
order you'll always get the same answer
that's a that's a property if you think
about kind of
making a kind of network that represents
in what order you do things
you'll get different orders for
different ways of multiplying things out
but you'll always get the same answer
same thing if you
let's say you're sorting you've got a
bunch of a's and b's they're in random
some random order you know b
a a b b b a a whatever and you have a
little rule that says
every time you see ba flip it around to
a b
okay eventually you apply that rule
enough times you'll have sorted the
string
so that it's all the a's first and then
all the b's
again you there are many different
orders in which you can do that
that term many different sort of places
where you can apply that update
in the end you'll always get the string
sorted the same way
i know i know with sorting string it
sounds obvious
that's to me is surprising that
that there is in complicated systems
obviously with this
with the string but in the hyper graph
that the application of the rule
is asynchronous rule can lead to the
same results sometimes
yes yes that is it is not obvious and it
was something that um
you know i i sort of discovered that
idea for these kinds of systems
and back in the 1990s and for various
reasons i
i i was not i was not satisfied by how
sort of fragile
finding that particular property was and
let me let me just make another point
which is that
that it turns out that even if the
underlying
rule does not have this property of
causal invariance
it can turn out that every observation
made by observers of the rule
can they can impose what amounts to
causal invariance
on the rule we can explain that it's a
little bit more complicated i mean
technically that has to do with this
idea of completions which is something
that comes up in term rewriting systems
automated theorem improving systems and
so on but that let's let's ignore that
for a second we'll we can come to that
later but is it useful to talk about
observation
not yet not yet so great
so there's some concept of causal
invariance as
you apply these rules in an asynchronous
way you can think of those
transformations
as events so there's this hyper graph
that represents space and all these
events
happening in the space and the graph
grows in interesting complicated ways
and eventually the froth arises to of uh
of what we experience as human
existence so that's that's that's the
that's some version of the picture but
but let's explain a little bit exactly
what's a little
a little more detail like right well so
so one thing
that is sort of surprising in this in
this theory is one of the sort of
achievements of 20th century physics was
kind of bringing space and time together
that was you know special relativity
people talk about space
time this sort of unified thing where
space and time kind of a mixed
and there's a nice mathematical
formalism um that uh in which
you know space and time sort of appear
as part of the space
time continuum the space time you know
four vectors and things like this
um you know we talk about time is the
fourth dimension and
all these kinds of things it's you know
the and it seems like
the ethereal activity sort of says space
and time are fundamentally the same kind
of thing
so one of the things that took a while
to understand
in in this approach of mine is
that uh in in my kind of approach space
and time are really not fundamentally
the same kind of thing space
is the extension of this hypergraph time
is the kind of progress of this
inexorable computation
of these rules getting applied to the
hypergraph so it's
they seem like very different kinds of
things and and so that
at first seems like how can that
possibly be right how can that possibly
be
lorentz invariant that's the term for
things being you know following the the
rules of special relativity
well it turns out that when you have
causal invariance
that and let's see we can it's worth
it's worth explaining a little bit how
this works it's a little bit a little
bit elaborate but
but the basic point is that um
uh the even though space and time sort
of
come from very different places it turns
out that the rules of sort of space-time
that special relativity talks about um
come out of this model when you're
looking at large enough systems
so so a way to think about this you know
in terms of the when you're looking at
large enough systems
um the part of that story is
when you look at some fluid like water
for example there are
equations that govern the flow of water
um
those equations are the things that
apply on a large scale
if you look at the individual molecules
they don't know anything about those
equations
it's just the the the sort of the large
scale effect of those molecules
turns out to follow those equations and
it's the same kind of thing happening in
our models
i know this might be a small point there
might be a very big one
we've been talking about space and time
at the lowest level of the model
which is space the hyper graph time is
the evolution of this hyper graph
but there's also space time that we
think about
and general relativity for your special
relativity
like what how does how do you
go from the uh lowest source code of
space and times we're talking about to
the more traditional terminology of
space
right so the key thing is this thing we
call the causal graph
so the causal graph is the graph of
causal relationships between events
so every one of these little updating
events every one of these little
transformations of the hypograph
happens somewhere in the hypograph
happens at some stage in the computation
that's an event that event is
has a causal relationship to other
events in the sense that
if the if another event needs as its
input
the output from the first event there
will be a causal relationship
of the the the future event will depend
on the past event
so you can say it's it has a causal
connection so you can make this graph
of causal relationships between events
that graph of causal relationships
causal invariance
implies that that graph is unique it
doesn't matter
even though you think oh i'm i'm you
know let's say we're sorting a string
for example
i did that particular transposition of
of characters
at this time then i did that one then i
did this one turns out if you look at
the network of
of connections between those updating
events
that network is the same it's it's the
if if you were to
see the the structure so in other words
if you were to draw that
that if you were to put that network on
a picture of where you're doing all the
updating
the places where you put the the nodes
of the network will be different
but the way the nodes are connected will
always be the same so but the
cause of graph is a is i don't know
it's kind of an observation it's not uh
enforced
it's just emergent from well it's it's
of okay so what it is characteristic i
guess is the way events happen
right it's an event can't happen until
its input is ready
right and so that creates this this
network of causal relationships
and that's that's the causal graph and
the thing that the next thing to realize
is
okay we when you're going to observe
what happens in the universe
you have to sort of make sense of this
causal graph
so and you are an observer who yourself
is part of this causal graph
and so that means so let me give you an
example of how that works so
so imagine we have a really weird theory
of physics of the world
where it says this updating process
there's only going to be one update at
every moment in time
and it's just going to be like a turing
machine it has a little head that runs
around and just is always just updating
one thing at a time so you say
you know i have a theory of physics and
the theory of physics says there's just
this one little place where things get
updated
you say that's completely crazy because
you know i it's
plainly obvious that things are being
updated sort of
you know yeah right but but
the fact is that the thing is that if
i'm
you know talking to you and you seem to
be being updated as i'm being updated
but
but if there's just this one little head
that's running around updating things
i will not know whether you've been
updated or not until i'm updated
so in other words right draw this causal
graph
of the causal relationship between the
updatings and you and the updatings in
me
it'll still be the same causal graph
whether even though
the underlying sort of story of what
happens it is
oh there's just this one little thing
and it goes and updates in different
places in the universe so
is that is that clear or is that a
hypothesis
is that is that clear that there's a
unique causal graph
uh if there's causal invariance there's
a unique cause of graph
so it's okay to think of what we're
talking about as a hypergraph and
the operations on it as a kind of
touring machine with a single head
like a single guy running around
updating stuff
um is that safe to intuitively think of
it this way um
let me think about that for a second yes
i think so i think that i think there's
nothing
it doesn't matter i mean you you can you
can say okay there is one
the reason i'm pausing for a second is
that um
i'm wondering well when you say running
around
depends how far it jumps every time it
runs out yeah yeah that's right
but i mean like one operation yeah you
can think of it as one operation
it's easier for the human brain to think
of it that way as opposed to uh well
it's not okay but the thing is that's
not how we experience the world
what we experience is we look around
everything seems to be happening at
successive moments in time everywhere in
space
yes that is the um and that's partly a
feature of
our particular construction i mean that
is the speed of light is really fast
compared to you know we look around you
know i can see maybe a hundred feet away
right now
um you know it's uh the my brain
does not process very much in the time
it takes light to go 100 feet
the brain operates at a scale of
hundreds of milliseconds or something
like that i don't know
right and speed of light is much faster
right you know light goes uh in a
billionth of a second light has gone a
foot so it goes a billion feet every
second
there's certain moments through this
conversation where i
i imagine the absurdity of the fact that
there's two descendants of apes
modeled by hypergraph that are
communicating with each other and
experiencing this whole
thing as a real time simultaneous update
with uh
i'm taking in photons from you right now
but there's something
much much deeper going on right here it
does have a it's paralyzing sometimes
just yes to remember that right no i
mean
you know but so you know yes yes no as a
small little tangent i just remembered
that we're talking about i mean this
that about
the fabric of reality
right so we've we've got this causal
graph that represents the sort of causal
relationships between all these events
in the universe
yeah that causal graph kind of is a
representation of space time
but our experience of it requires that
we pick
reference frames this is kind of a key
idea einstein had this idea
that what that means is we have to say
what are we going to pick as being
the uh sort of what we define as
simultaneous moments in time
so for example we can say um you know
we we set how do we set our clocks you
know if we've got a spacecraft
landing on mars you know do we say that
it you know what what time is it landing
at was it
you know even though there's a 20-minute
speed of light delay or something
you know what time do we say it landed
at how do we how do we set up
sort of time coordinates for for the
world and that turns out to be
that there's kind of this arbitrariness
to how we set these reference frames
that define sort of what cancels
simultaneous
and what is the the essence of special
relativity is to think about
reference frames going at different
speeds and to think about sort of how
they assign
what counts the space what counts as
time and so on
um that's all a bit technical but the
basic bottom line is
that the this causal and variance
property
that means that it's always the same
causal graph independent of how you
slice it with these reference frames
you'll always sort of see the same
physical processes go on
and that's basically why special
relativity works
you